[Music]
we're going to be doing something a
little different this week we're taking
the show on the road and doing this
week's interview in a remote studio
joining me is a personal hero of mine a
former guest on the Rubin report and now
someone that I'm incredibly proud to
call a friend
ayaan Hirsi Ali ion's life story is a
true testament to the human spirit which
shows that any of us including a little
girl born in Somalia who underwent
female genital mutilation can make
anything with their life and really show
what the human spirit is all about if
you want to test people and whether they
truly truly stand for liberalism
tolerance and Western values just ask
them what they think of ayaan Hirsi Ali
the people who really believed in the
individual and in human rights will be
firmly in her corner while those who
stand for moral relativism and
collectivist thinking will be against
her in an unfortunate sign of time
speaking your mind as ayaan does comes
with a certain cost so unfortunately we
can't share the location of where we did
the interview but I do want to take a
moment and thank everyone who helps
facilitate it and without any further
ado here's my chat with ayaan Hirsi Ali
[Music]
all right we are on location this week
and I am with activist and author and
one of my favorite people on the planet
and now I can call you friend ayaan
Hirsi Ali
welcome to the Rubin report David thank
you very much thank you for having me
some I can't believe that somehow this
is our first time sitting down in person
that's right we did all the skies a few
times I guess and yeah yeah here we a
lot of email yeah yeah
so I said to you last night that what I
don't want to do today for this hour is
just tell your story again because it's
been told so many times it's an
incredible story for you it must be sort
of exhausting to tell it over and over
and we'll link to it below so that
people can get it if they don't know it
but is there one piece of your story
that you think has either been
misconstrued or is an important piece
that people haven't quite got or
anything like that well it's the reason
why I tell it at all which is I use it
to illustrate that it's possible you
know to be born in Africa grow up in a
Muslim household and go through all
sorts of adversities and come out whole
and wholesome and healthy and what I see
sometimes what's of my opponents use is
they say oh she went through all of
these terrible things and she's angry
she says and for she's miserable and so
she's using Islam to get back at I'm
happy childhood and I think that's false
yeah and especially now that I've gotten
to know you a little bit I don't sense
any of that I said I mean there's such
light in you and goodness and all of
those things and I don't sense any of
that but we're sort of just stuck in a
situation where even by talking about
this it's somehow they want to project
something on you right at that site but
I mean if you look at the arguments of
my opponents what you see is they run
out of logical consistent they they want
to defend a system of life or a theory
for life that is intolerant that is
anti-women anti-gay that conflates
religion with politics and some of them
really honest ones defend it and go all
the way to say you know
this philosophy is better than all other
man-made philosophies and they talk good
all the terrible stuff that's the
outcome but the ones who believe in it
and promote it and yet you know find
themselves in this what I what I think
of as cognitive dissonance yeah the
other ones who would use anything so
fastly they say she has no experience
then I put my experience at the table
and they say okay that's bad that's
because you're traumatized and things
are not in the Quran and I show them
what's in the Quran they say yeah you
misinterpret it or you know you're doing
something other than what it says yeah
and on and on and on it goes I think
it's just it's people who have no
argument or weak argument to take refuge
in inconsistencies and just last night
we spent some time with some people that
really had interesting arguments and we
didn't all agree on things which I
thought was was wonderful and people
people were quoting the Quran and and
all of this stuff and and that's what
discussion is about which is why this
whole thing is so related to free speech
and everything so instead of talking
about some of the critics let's talk
about your new your new book should we
call it a book or a booklet or a what
should we officially call it I started
out as a white prisoner yeah it's now a
booklet and I hope to expand it to a
book and you know start treating other
subjects such as a simulation that are
not in the booklet but it's an argument
I'm basically saying in there that there
is this time Dola and that non-muslims
and Muslims should know about I know
that most people here if you ask them
about jihad they they have something to
say about it they may not agree on what
it means but most people are familiar
with the term jihad right if you
understand you had to be a holy struggle
or a holy war against infidels against
unbelievers then that you have to
understand that there is this whole
process that is its prior to jihad and
that is Dawa yeah so when you talk about
diet what you're really talking about
it's political Islam which is which is
separate it's not independent of but
it's separate than what we think of as
religious Islam right
yeah I think I like talking about
individuals because it's individuals who
take actions and then there is the
doctrine of Islam so I think from the
get-go you have to separate Islam as a
doctrine for Muslims as adherence and
Muslims do you ever feel it no matter
how much you do that that a certain set
of people just won't let you do that
because because I do it every week here
whenever we talk about this and a
certain amount of people just no matter
how many times you do that yeah they're
just not going to have it they're not
going to have it but I'll do it
literally I think it's very important to
separate this doctrine from the people
and if you look at the adherence what
they do is they look at the doctrine and
they select out of the doctrine what
they want so if you look at the Islamic
doctrine Islamic history Islamic
scripture you will see that politics and
religion are intertwined but there are
many Muslims who just stick to what is
Villages they'll say look I pray I fast
I would like to go to a Mecca or they go
to Mecca if they can afford to but other
than that they're really and the
attitude toward other people whether
they're Muslims or non-muslims and
they're just truly Geocities to say
until you your religion or unto me my
right and all of this is in Islam yeah
so for those people I like to describe
him as Mecca Muslims yeah because what
they're doing is they're selecting out
of that whole doctrine the bits and
pieces that were revealed in Mecca to
Muhammad so Muhammad the founder of
Islam when he was mad in Mecca he was
saying certain things he was behaving in
a certain way and there is that legacy
and they like to stick to that Mecca
Muslims how many they are I can't tell
you I think they probably could be the
largest number of Muslims maybe they're
decreasing in number now because the
other group the medina Muslims the ones
who look at Muhammad's life and legacy
and take whatever it is that he
established in Medina which is heavy on
politics heavy on military those are the
Muslims that engage in Dawa so so when
we talk about this Mecca and Medina
stand the history of this and all that
do you sometimes fear that by focusing
too much on that that we end up getting
lost in historical things that don't
necessarily tie us fully to what's
happening now
well there's always a risk of getting
lost in in history but I think in terms
of trying to differentiate because we
live in at a time when we really have to
make it very clear that not all Muslims
are dangerous or that not all Muslims
are a threat to us and in doing so you
have to fight you have to really mind
your language
and you have to find ways in separating
those who are a potential threat or RFS
and are Muslim because you and I and I
think many more people now agree with us
that some of the phenomena of jihad we
are seeing has its roots in Islam if you
believe that it doesn't then you can go
and get lost in history and other
discussions because you always want to
take a discussion off the table right
but if you're all again so basically you
can always find some historical event to
pin on instead of what comes from dark
yeah so again if we go back to you know
let's look at individuals which it's an
individual who takes part in discussions
and there are people who are taking part
in this discussion in the confrontation
between Islam and the West and Islam in
the rest of the world and who just
happened to believe
Islam as with religion as a doctrine has
nothing to do with what we are seeing
Islam has nothing to do with Isis or
al-qaeda or Boko Haram or al-shabaab
with terrorism with jihad with misogyny
none of that work and I think it's very
I don't know about you but it's very
difficult for me to talk about this
subject with those people yeah because I
feel like if their job is to deflect and
mine is to eliminate as much as possible
and I think it's helpful if we can
pinpoint exactly what it is about Islam
that we don't like and that's a threat
and more importantly who are the Muslims
who are seeking to use Islam as a tool
for political power for domination for
misogyny and to justify the
unjustifiable throwing people from tall
places to the Deaf killing and enslaving
women
Forge agitating anti-semitism you know
we thought with after 1945 at the end of
the Second World War that there was
enormous insight in the West
normal anti-semitism never again and now
it's become if you I don't know how
often you visit or go to Europe but in
Europe anti-semitism is back and it's
back because of his love yeah so okay so
there's there's a bunch there so when
people talk about these books one of the
things that I'll hear people say as well
wait a minute the the Old Testament has
a ton of bad stuffing yes I suspect you
wouldn't disagree with that the New
Testament actually has less bad out of
the three if you were looking them in
terms of violence I think the New
Testament is certainly the least violent
of the three but what is the difference
then that that makes the individuals act
on one of them more than the others is
it just that this is the newest one and
it hasn't gone through that Reformation
or that maturation or whatever or is it
specifically yeah the the point of the
text well I think historically if you
look at the history of Christianity
you'll see that there's been a lot of
internal fighting about what
Christianity should mean or the place of
the Old Testament the place of the New
Testament it was this whole process of
Reformation the Enlightenment and beyond
even post-modernism is part of you know
the place of Christianity and one of the
things that I think made it easier for
Christians to move forward was that from
the get-go politics and religion were
separate so you couldn't be declared not
to be Christian if you've proposed or
you are proponent of manmade laws and
rules with Islam we're not yet there and
there have been individuals in the
history of Islam who fought for a
separation of religion from politics
they've all been marginalized they've
been forgotten by most Muslims they are
celebrated only by non-muslims in the
Christian world but they have they've
unto this day that are Muslims I call
them performers I call them modifies
itself that group
mr. Mecca to Medina and the modifiers
race to this day you have these Muslims
who wants to modernize who want to
rehabilitate separate politics from
religion so that no one no religious
person uses Islam as a tool for
political domination but again they're
marginalized aside like to threatened so
is this the ultimate failing of what the
frustrations that we and many others
have with the left that they have
actually held Islam hostage in a weird
way because every time someone comes out
and says I want to reform the say
through you know what marginalize is
trying to do with Quilliam Foundation
and many other people now and
unfortunately as we were talking about
you know there is a growing movement
there but every time they step out of
that lane yeah they get slammed so it
really it's the it's the Liberals
unfortunately the left yeah that is
holding the more extreme elements of
Islam in power I think that a part of it
of course yeah so there's there's the
internal dynamics of Islam and Muslims
and how they fight out what to retain of
Islam and what not - yeah and then there
are the external pressures and I think
what when we talk about because this is
really relevant for Muslims living
inside Western countries with a left and
a right where they left find themselves
I just want to say inadvertently I can't
believe that they really mean it that
they're doing this consciously and
willing it yeah but they find themselves
in Italy aligned whether it is lowest
I've had some people say that because
the left hates America
the left hates capitalism the left can't
deal with political freedom and to find
another group with a similar outlook
even though they want to see a different
outcome right and that it's easy very
natural for the far left to align itself
not only with Islam and Islamism but
also with other radical anti Western
movie lines and and this is basically
what intersectionality is right these
sort of oppressed groups that are coming
together and these quote-unquote
oppressed groups
are coming together to form something
bigger even if they're their own what
they want at the end of the day is
actually very different when I look at
people talk about intersectionality and
and all you know this whole identity
politics thing what I see is taking the
human being
magnifying a biological attribute and
then putting them aside putting them in
a corner as victims of oppression and in
a way I feel sorry for them I happen to
be black and I happen to be a woman and
I happen to be a minority in the United
States
I even happened to be an apostate really
going for the whole thing yes so talk
about intersectionality yeah but none of
that defines me as Who I am I'm more
than all of that and I most certainly
don't see myself as a victim and knowing
people who grew up in Africa who grew up
in Muslim countries you probably know
also some gay people who had to struggle
and go through adversity I think when
you come out of it you come out as a
proud survivor you don't come out as a
victim and you don't want to be
victimized you don't want safe spaces
you don't want to be in this constant
mental state of anger and full of
resentment and wanting to lash out at
others and demanding that society or
whoever it is that you feel oppresses
you gives you money and jobs and no you
come out of this thinking and I've and I
love that work you know I what I'm proud
of in my journey is that I was able to
say every time when I tried to run away
from that husband yeah some of the
Somalis around me would say you're going
to rot in hell and there's absolutely no
way you're going to survive outside of
the extended family the plan you will
end up being a [ __ ]
you know and now at the age of 47 I want
to look back and tell them that didn't
happen yeah I didn't end up being a
[ __ ] I don't think I'm going to burn in
hell because I don't
and I have a wonderful comfortable life
that I couldn't have if I had gone with
that man yeah so that doesn't make me
into a victim
intersectionality or no
intersectionality you know so to me the
whole thing the whole hog wash off you
know the language I try to go through
some of these articles and books and
they're so boring yeah it's just one
long excuse to wallow in self-pity and
that's not they don't those people don't
speak for all blacks for all women for
all minorities they just speak for in my
view a very small subsection of other
privileged individuals who yeah who are
seeking to take advantage of the trend
now of white guilt yeah so is the irony
that it may not even be exactly what you
say that is getting for the for your
critics it's not exactly what you're
saying which if you've probably whittled
it down they might agree with you on
some of it privately at least but it's
that you don't act like a victim and
they can't that is so counter yeah to
the entire movement that even if think
you could get them to privately say you
know yeah yeah you're making some good
point but that your very existence as a
free functioning happy successful person
yes is counter to their moving backs
more of a threat than whatever you can
say about Islam or anything else that's
effect and the leadership within this
movement I have no idea what to call
them you brought up the term
intersectional are they called
intersectional god knows what they're
called they love the oppression Olympics
which I heard first from our friend
angel yeah yeah yeah what some of it I
mean look at college campuses there are
freshmen young vulnerable students
impressionable minds and their heads are
filled with these nonsense that you know
they have to fear for their lives and
that they are not safe on campus in
American campuses and it's that kind of
leadership that I find so toxic because
here you have young people in my view I
mean I come from Africa people would
kill to be in winning any one of these
ivory universities and get an education
yeah and here they are being
so that if they read Plato or
Shakespeare or Mark Twain there are
certain somehow yeah in that there's
rape culture there okay and in this I
you know what are you doing to these
young people
yeah so we're with that where do you
think the fault lies because I agree
with you I think a lot of the people
that have bought into these ideas I
don't blame the the eighteen-year-old
kid who has been hit with this stuff and
indoctrinated I don't blame that kid
yeah I would hopefully we'll fight to
save some of their intellect at some
point hopefully they'll hear some of our
good ideas but who do you blame do you
blame the administrators first you and
we're cultists so thankful for putting
these stupid programs together and I
think those programs should not be
funded and of course the administrators
the faculty you blame the people who are
supposed to be the grown-ups in the room
and for them to you know sign off on
these programs where young people are
being scared to death on campuses and
it's not here's the paradox the people
that they are supposed to protect and
one is feeling protective of other ones
who get disadvantaged ultimately because
you and you make people feel nothing
else but their skin color or nothing
else but their gender or their
transgendered Ness or whatever it is
other biological attributes and for four
years or five years you're in a setting
where your demands are met or supposedly
met I think usually people just ignore
it right which would be the best thing
to do actually I think you would think
that but then you you graduate and then
you go into you start taking part in
real life and then I wonder what has
this institution of learning and dance
for these young people what what has it
done to them yeah so if you were
advising a school that was going through
this where every week we see another
school going through this and they're
they're you know they want a professor
fire they wanted to administrator fired
what would you say to them is I mean
okay so we can defund some of this stuff
but is it really that we have to teach
courses on this I mean teach the reverse
course they're learning identity
politics do we need a counter course yes
we need a
individuality causes we need more
crosses on the American Constitution
yeah the individuals who founded this
country in the adversities that they
went through I would propose more
programs on Western civilization what
makes it distinct from other
civilizations from other cultures and I
would most definitely emphasize when it
comes to freedom the position of the
individual not groups not individuals
you can pretend you're in some kind of
group with all black people but that's
not the case you are an individual and
your circumstances are different from
other peoples and I think when you want
you know people say well if you're going
through the same sort of suffering or
through the same kind of adversity it
does help to organize and it does most
certainly and to put on the table
exactly what it is that these problems
are and together to work out as a group
but the members in that group are
voluntary yes
they actually say you know I'm working
with some Muslim women who understand
that Sharia as a system of law is really
something that's applied to their daily
lives that compromises their freedom
compromises their dignity and as a group
they don't see themselves as victims of
anything else other than this particular
culture that's practiced by their own
parents their own extended family their
own community and they wants to change
and they want to change these
communities but outside of that outside
of those few hours when they're
highlighting these issues there are
three individuals going about their
daily life so I'm glad you brought up
Sheree and I want to get to that in a
second but I said at the beginning I
wasn't going to ask you about the past
again but I think I'm something that I
get people asking about like you know
when they'll ask me when did you wake up
to this stuff and start talking about
some of this stuff so for you was there
actually a moment like was it when you
left Somalia and then from then on this
idea about individualism and all this
really stuck with you or was it as your
travels continued and some of the some
of it well the bad things that happened
to now some of the good things like was
there really a moment where your
ideology got crystal
it was gradual and I didn't have an
ideology I just you know felt the pain
of being told you can't do this you have
to do that and being resentful and
feeling powerless and thinking well I
can I would like to do something I don't
want to marry this man because I don't
want to end up like my mother and like
all these other women I've grown up
around who feels powerless emotionally
trapped in this who and who who really
wonder what is life all about while all
this suffering when is there something I
can do as an individual to be different
and to make my own circumstances
different so when I went to Holland and
I found people and a society and a
culture that actually made it possible
and enhanced all of that I started to
think about not so much you know develop
an account ideology but just try and
understand what's this all about and my
years enlightened I went to the
University of Leiden no safe spaces
none of that no figures yes III got
introduction to all the various
philosophies that preceded the one that
we enjoyed at that point in time in the
Netherlands and then 9/11 happened and
you know that brought the issue of Islam
for me as a Muslim as a former Muslim at
the time I identified as a Muslim and so
I found myself in 2001 2002 thinking
about okay how does always relate to me
and what is where do I stand in this
yeah okay so so from there then let's go
back now to Sharia and to daolon to
political Islam how do we talk about
this in a way that that's not going to
make people crazy we've already got the
idea of ideas and people that these are
different things and you've already
talked about that there are a certain
amount of course of people Muslims that
are good people as you said we don't
even know what that number is it could
be a much bigger number than people
might think we we have-we don't know but
how do we how do we explain the dangers
of what political Islam is without
getting lost in the mess we use the
tools that we use to explain other
threats and other dangers as long as
you're consistent
if you are studying HIV you have to talk
you have to learn something about
viruses and you have to know something
about infections and you have to know
something about blood-to-blood
transmissions and you know all the ways
that that virus behaves if you're
studying cancers and other fats malaria
all of that you've got to know
everything about the causes the vectors
and all the other environmental issues
that excessive ate the problem with
Islam I find that very often we talk
about symptoms we talk about the
environment we talk about
disenfranchised young men we talk about
countries that feel that because they
have autocratic and you know they have
dictatorships that maybe the populations
are acting out in a certain way but we
hardly ever talk about the cooperation
and as far as I'm concerned if we want
to defeat what it is that makes Isis
Islamic State of Iraq and Syria is so
attractive and al Qaeda and all these
other groups so attractive we will not
be able to do that without learning
something about the life and legacy of
Muhammad the founder of Islam about part
of that legacy is the Quran what is what
is it that he says was revealed to me
and how does that operate in the
day-to-day lives of people yeah the
leadership the Saudi Arabian government
spent billions of dollars spreading part
of that legacy across the entire world
that is an activity that's Dao that's an
activity to Islamize non Islamic
societies and to strengthen Islam or
radical Islam or political Islam within
majority Muslim societies so if we don't
understand if we don't scrutinize these
activities and don't analyze them
properly we will always be chasing the
symptoms yeah and this so this is what
we see when we see that Germany that the
amount of mosques in
that are funded by Saudi Arabia is up by
some I don't know the percentages but
it's some crazy percentage and that
they're teaching these ideas so what
what is the goal then when they say
we're you know what what is the goal of
dolla is it truly to turn these Western
countries into Islamic nations to have a
bunch of westernized people actually
suddenly living under Sharia law it's to
Islam eyes and you know the president of
Turkey IDO on it's very explicit about
it when he's speaking in Turkish he
wants to Islamize Europe he advises
immigrants Muslim immigrants to have
more children because he thinks that's
the fastest way and government's like
that of Saudi Arabia and Qatar and
quickly pump a lot of money into Western
societies and target immigrant groups
and asked them not to assimilate because
to assimilate means less Islamization
and to create these parallel societies
where they live by what I call Sharia
light and Sharia like always that with
trying to cover up women and having hip
establishing Sharia councils where
marriage and divorce laws and laws of
custody women are persuaded not to take
advantage of or to recognize the normal
secular laws that project it so this is
literally a set of laws that exists sort
of parallel to our our regular second
doors but it replaces them and and this
is what people certain people are living
under yeah it's now become a reality and
ever larger numbers of Muslims adopting
this sharia light and this idea that at
some point Europe is going to be
Islamist and the West can't be turned
against itself to become Islamic now
what we see is there are those groups
who use force and violence they use
terrorism and then there are the
government and the legitimate they're
called legitimate because we are not
using violence that at least that's how
these regards that are working within
the system to expand the number of
people who accept willingly that these
sharia light laws apply to them so they
create
parallel communities of parallel
societies now are they going to really
succeed in their goal of Islamize in
Europe I don't know I hope not I don't
think so but they are trying yeah and I
think there's nothing wrong in
recognizing the fact that they actually
try yeah so do we get lost in too much
of the violence I mean if you were to
ask the average person who you know who
doesn't know that much about this they'd
say well I'm mostly concerned because I
see trucks driving into people in Sweden
and shootings in Paris and the pulse
nightclub in Orlando and cetera et
cetera but that that really may be a
distraction from from really what's
going on like do these things work
together are the jihadis and the
Islamist even though you're saying
they're totally different
yeah the ideologies are different are
they somehow include well our Liberal
government do what I think primarily
governments must do which is protect
people from terrorist activities so we
have intelligence communities that are
monitoring individuals and groups who
are planning the next terrorist attack
and I think that should continue but the
rest of us who are not monitoring
terrorists agree we should understand
the process before the jihad so before a
guy jumps in a cow in a truck with a
knife in his hand or in a gun in his
hands you've got to understand what it
how is it that this man came to this
conclusion he's going to kill strangers
people he doesn't know what is it and
when you look at the history of all the
people who've been cops and were able to
talk about it they just say I'm doing it
because I believe that it's my religion
they believe that they are going to
heaven for doing it and the more you
listen to them the more you compare the
notes to what they hear in mosques and
what start is Lama Cruz what is preached
sometimes on the street it is all this
non-violent activity that is taking full
advantage exploiting the freedom of
association freedom of religion the
freedom of speech to spread this idea
among people that is I think when we as
a society should wake up to this and say
wait a second what is this message what
are these people teaching which groups
and individuals are they targeting what
is their objective and can we develop a
counter-narrative
and we have that counter-narrative we
don't even have to develop it we just
need to market it to those individuals
and groups that they target yeah I'm
perfectly happy to talk to and this is
these are the people that I would like
to talk to the prisoners the immigrants
everywhere and tell them listen you come
from a country where Sharia is actually
the law and you fled that country it's
not a great life you're now in a free
country do you know what the two
different philosophies and the two
different principle that each of these
countries is founded on this is what
Sharia countries that are founded on the
Sharia principle this is what they look
like in real life life is miserable
invisible for women it's miserable for
religious minorities it's miserable for
gays it's miserable for men it's right
it's miserable for most of the Muslim
people that live there I just want to be
free forget I think in this case a good
example is just forget the mine are you
think of the majority majority it's
miserable for everyone you look at these
other nation states that are founded on
the principle freedom of equality of
Tolerance hey life may not be what
heaven is painted out to be where you
can have 72 virgins at a time sorry yes
and drink wine much like a bit less so
it's not you know that's fantastical in
your topic and in my view kind of you
know really stupid yeah but I wouldn't
even use the word stupid I would just
say hey it might not be as business ID
as that yeah but you know you're free to
do what you want in life is stable its
predictable you can have your friends in
your community you can build you can
have a passion and develop it you can
indulge your senses art music love for
cooking love for others it's so much
more attractive in fact when I came to
Holland and
in America often I think but this is
paradise yeah I want to live as long as
possible yeah I don't want to go to this
promised paradise and so we have to
start to talk talking to the same
audiences about is there really an
afterlife was Muhammad really moral
should you really follow everything that
Muhammad said to this day so are there
some things that are unacceptable I mean
it's a few centuries later right and I
want you to at least be able to talk
about it yeah at the very least and we
should talk about this in elementary
schools in high schools in universities
that's where young people are we should
use cultural tools the cinema music
everything to try and influence them to
make these choices but we've got to make
them aware of this other choice the
principles of freedom because that's not
where they come from they don't know it
so is that really where the West has
failed that you know your phrase about
the tolerance of intolerance and you're
making a very clear case that they want
to use our tolerance against us and yet
our tolerance is so built-in to the West
of course we have problems and there's
you know we have monetary just you know
people have all sorts a different amount
of money and all kinds of problems and
there of course are still people that
are racist and all of those things yeah
but that are basic tolerance and is now
being turned on us and we haven't done a
good job selling it right because we do
find out that a lot of these jihadists
yeah they don't come from poor families
many of them come from well-to-do
families and many of them are well
educated in all those things yeah which
if we would push that idea out more
perhaps it would give us a little more
credit in what we're trying to do and
what we're trying to do yeah I think it
is the recognition that it is not like
we talked about the symptoms it's not
because people are pouring fact I think
people are poor because if the principle
of Sharia is the prevailing principle
people will be poor you're not Sharia is
not about making money sure is about
trying to adhere to a set of rules very
blindly that are economically unfriendly
and that increase inequality and we look
at the position of women if you lock up
women that when you keep them ignorant
you're going to have a society that's
extremely poor and with great
equality with Sharia it may be well
intended whatever the intentions are I
can't see the well in there but you are
also creating circumstances for the
abuse of power power is concentrated in
the hands of very few people the
clergymen who believe that they can tell
you the difference between right and
wrong who put themselves on God's seat
so it's just it opens the doors
alternates pure exploitation yeah and we
in the West we have sale to sell and I
think part of it is because the people
present-day Westerners didn't do the
fighting you know they were not the
young hungry scrappy men that made this
country the other ones who inherited it
after several generations so people
don't know I remember being in Holland
and seeing you know this this idea of
freedom was it was the identity of the
Dutch man at the almost a biological
identity look it's all for granted they
couldn't understand why people didn't
just adapt yeah yeah they didn't think
that it is they didn't see that it was
something that they had learned from
their parents and their environment the
parents had learned from their parents
and it I always compared to you know
wealthy children of wealthy family
businesses the first generation is the
one that makes the money the next
generation kind of knows what the first
generation went through they're
conscious of the fact that they have to
carry these responsibilities forward but
ultimately a generation comes that just
spends and doesn't know where it all
comes from yeah
and part of me thinks you know we're
living at a time when lots of Westerners
are really spending this legacy of
freedom and they don't know they don't
know what it is not to be free they
don't know what it what inequality
really means when we're talking about
inequality of outcomes yeah I'm talking
about this idea that is ingrained in
people outside of the West that they
have an inferior spot in that that's
their spot yeah
so as women you're in Korea in a caste
system you belong to your caste and you
can never come out of it and there's no
social mobility or if there's social
mobility it's because of Western
influence it's not an organic thing that
comes out of these cultures so
Westerners just think you know people
will come to it yeah and it's just it's
just simply not true it's not true and
it's dangerous because if you don't if
we don't engage in a dollar for freedom
we're going to be overtaken by the
dollar for Sharia so one of the things
that I've been trying to figure out and
with a bunch of our allies some of that
I've had on my show I've been saying I'm
finding it a lot easier right now to
build bridges with people that are
thought of as more traditionally on the
right because at least it's rooted in
the individual which is obviously a big
part of everything you're talking about
yeah do you see room to build anything
left with what is the the modern left
for the most part so for example they'll
they'll prop up someone like Linda
Sarsour and basically not ever offer you
a platform or even for me I only get
invited to colleges from the Young
Republicans and libertarians and the
freedom yeah this and that and I think
it's probably very similar to you I
think that your observation that people
who identify as conservative in this
country and ironically a liberal in
Europe right right which is another
thing which we have a show on the
Internet and all the words get April
crazy yeah yeah
so people who identify as conservative
in this country in the United States of
America they find it so much easier to
see you know what is unfree about so
many of these non-western cultures I
find it so much easier to talk to Tucker
Carlson on Fox News about female genital
mutilation and I really appreciate his
you know the horrified look on his show
on his face and the fact that he thinks
this is a practice he doesn't care where
it's justified in the name of culture or
religion or tell it
needs to stop and he is going to use his
influence in his position to make that
point and then I look at the New York
Times one of these New York Times
editors who says you know what maybe we
should in order for these coaches to
come or to lessen - to narrow the gap
between this culture and that culture
maybe we need to stop calling mutilation
and call it a cut or whatever and that I
learn I mean it is literal you're not
making this up this I'm not really that
it was written yeah it was her name is
escaping me yeah but when I when I look
at that kind of reasoning that kind of
logic and I look here as a free woman
she calls herself a liberal she is with
probably the most powerful newspaper in
the United States of America as all this
influence why on earth is she making
this terrible trade-off and the
trade-off is this is it the individual
who's actually going through the
mutilation or potentially may go through
the mutilation and that individual is a
child four five six years old seven
years old sometimes younger some coaches
they start at infancy and versus some
vague abstract notion called culture or
some kind of group so people will come
and present themselves grownups and say
well if you call it mutilation then I'm
offended to my core yeah so this is what
the omar describes as the soft bigotry
of low expectations yeah right like we
have to change all the words and never
say what things exactly are yeah this
could inflame this is but that goes to
you you know conservatives versus
liberals and it becomes so much easier
for people like me for people who come
from the countries where this these
terrible things take place in it is
justified in the name of culture and
religion and a combination of the two
that we think yeah conservatives are our
friends yeah because you know they may
have a very passionate position on
closing borders and getting illegals out
and all of these things but when it
comes to honor killings when it comes to
female genital mutilation when it comes
to you know if you're a gay Muslim man
just imagine what you're going through
when it comes to all this Muslim
opposites we find that people
conservatives in this country make it so
much easier yeah yeah I spoke at
University of Arizona a couple weeks ago
and I'm saying hi to some of the kids
after and a kid came up to me and I
could see he was really nervous and he
was shaking a little bit and he said to
me that watching my show has helped him
you know think about some things that
many told me he said I've never told him
on this but I'm X Muslim yeah and then
he said to me and something else I'm
also like you yeah he was gay and he
just he couldn't really say it and I
didn't I didn't even know what to do and
he was starting to cry and I just hugged
him and yeah I was kind of tearing up
yeah and I thought this is the ultimate
irony here yeah Here I am with the I
forget it was a young Republicans or
whatever group it was yeah and here is
where he had to come for refuge and yet
they all be slammed as the people who
are racists and bigots and homophobes in
oh yeah but ironically again in 2017
it's the conservatives who take very
clear positions on critical Islam on
anti-semitism on the killing of gays
some of them may be against gay marriage
but here we have a religion that says
gays should be killed
you never come out of the closet because
you risk getting killed by your own
family so in that sense I think it's it
there is a big shameful smear on the
people who describe themselves as
liberals and who make excuses for these
cultures these low expectations and the
faces of bigotry of low expectations
yeah so I'll put you on the spot here if
if more left-wing outlets and I said to
us and I get the same thing I only get
invited when I get TV things it's only
from Fox people say why are you why are
you going to miss NBC targets I can't
bust down their door so but if you got
more invites from the things that are
thought of as liberal
left or import invited to schools or
wherever else you would do that correct
right well I would do that I have I have
a relationship with CNN I've been on
their show many times when you know
something happens I have I hide for The
Daily Beast once in a while it's not
they're not monolithic and within every
organization there are individuals you
know who just you know computer common
sense yeah say these things are inhuman
these are violations of our human rights
and these things should stop but very
often I also hear I can't say this I
can't do this because the rest of the
organization doesn't want it and they
prioritize other subjects or they let
the Muslim Brotherhood front groups take
the stage and and sedate them basically
into saying that Islam is a religion of
peace and none of these things has to do
with Islam and Muslims in America are
victims of Islamophobia and this is then
yeah I mean I can see as you're saying
it's so ridiculous to you that you're
sort of laughing as you're saying it so
like when you say that you're talking
about basically a group like care yeah
every time something happens yeah within
ten seconds yeah I'm probably giving it
an extra nine seconds yeah there
immediately I'm talking about
Islamophobia as opposed to the victims
or the certainly not the ideology or the
rest of it yeah you're saying that this
this is part of Dawa this is part of a
lot of Dawa because what they have seen
is it is this weakness in the West is a
colleague of mine at Hoover shall be
still whom I really respect and admire
he calls it white guilt and this white
guilt was there before there were any
Muslims in the United States of America
but organizations like the Council of
American Islamic relations they series
and they exploded and sometimes they
manufacture these you know they talk
about a backlash no backlash ever
happens and then they start
manufacturing stories so all I mean you
look at the FBI makes these reports on
hate crimes and you see that again in
the United States of America
unfortunately
the num the largest number of recorded
hate crimes is against Jews there is a
little bit against Muslims and then even
some of that ends up being your
manufacture yes and when care uses cases
like those they don't tell the public or
but this case has been debunked they
simply keep using it yeah and the whole
point is they see that people feel
guilty and it's a way of shutting people
up it's a way of stopping them from
questioning and then what you get is
that people start talking about instead
of talking about it openly in open
platforms you see you hear people talk
about it you know behind closed doors
and on birthdays scenes where you can't
really have a proper debate from both
sides right and then it's unhealthy
well it's unhealthy but then the irony
is that then you know a terrorist attack
happens they immediately do that and
then the only time that these networks
put some of the reformers or the
ex-muslim semaj it or you or whoever
else they only put them on right asked
when the when the feelings are still raw
yeah I mean we're doing this hopefully
nothing happened while we're doing this
and we'll put it out and it'll be for
people to learn yeah but but the media
now at least cable news is so reactive
yeah that you have these competing
things that are that make no sense
together you have the reaction of it's
Islamophobia as I think you said in one
of the things the bodies were still
flatworm yeah
and then and then or you have the
reaction of they only put you on while
it's happening and it's still raw so
it's like a competing forces oh they
frame a story in such a way that oh you
know Major Nidal Malik Hasan attack
whose workplace violence Orlando was
just another gay hating man and it has
nothing to do with what are you saying
right you do you know and had he been
Christian of course they would have said
could have found the most light
connection to Christianity yeah the left
would have went bananas with this and
they would have said you see the
Westboro Baptist Church and the
Christians are doing this yeah but they
and that's what's causing the backlash
because they're going so out of there
they're bending over backwards
yeah and they starting to look
ridiculous there is no backlash you see
right we live in a country
about three hundred three million three
three million of a million three hundred
million three hundred twenty-five
million people and if you look at again
these FBI records it's really minimal
you don't see her backlash you see the
opposite
you see people Americans saying you're
I'm going to protect my [ __ ] Yeah
right you see rabbis and Christian
priests and the leadership going out and
organizing more interface Muslims being
welcome everywhere you don't see a
backlash they've been saying this in
Europe they've been saying it is no
battle right we see the area where the
only hell write something mean and then
half of them turn out to be fake it's
like yeah yeah and by the way that
happens on all sides that whole thing
about the JCC is the Jewish Community
Center is being called we turned out to
be an Israeli those Jewish Israeli so so
again you can see things bad wherever
they were yeah but when something like
that happens within the Jewish community
Jewish communities because there are
several Jewish communities they get
incensed and they stop it and they come
out to say yes this is one of us this
guy is one of us and for whatever reason
he is doing it it needs to be stopped
but when you look at the Muslim
leadership have you seen anyone come out
among you know the organized Muslim
groups to say let's stop this now
this whole bogus Islamophobia charge
let's stop it let's do away with it yeah
you don't see that what you see are
people like us earn our money and the
other Muslim performers who are saying
we don't feel the backlash as Muslims in
fact we are more scared of these
organized Islamists then we are about
some kind of extreme right-wing backlash
that never happens right okay so I want
to before we finish I want to talk a
little bit at the end about your
foundation and what you're doing because
I think you're you're building some new
things now that I think are important
and a network to stop a network I think
is loosely what you said before which
yeah that's what we need but I do want
to send a couple minutes talking about
female genital mutilation because we've
mentioned it I read your piece and about
it and you describe the five types and
it's horrific and the only reason I want
to talk about it is because it was
because reading it and even the way you
wrote it I think after the third
type yeah you said this is getting hard
to read it was hard to read from the
beginning so it's like that effect and
really I really was having trouble
reading I mean it's so this really awful
so we can go through all of them if you
want but we don't have to but can you
just for a couple of minutes just lay
out what's going on there because people
are now hearing it and you're right when
the New York Times and says well it's
cutting yeah and you know last night you
described oh yeah they're in some
academics say this has been going on for
a long time it must have some kind of
value and that we as Westerners don't
understand so we should just let it be
yeah well so we'll link to the article
down below so people can read it but if
you want to just lay out a little bit of
it well the first thing I want to point
out is this is being done to children
it's being done to girls little girls
vulnerable by people they trust their
parents their extended family
grandmothers aren't a lot of women are
involved in keeping distractors in place
they have their reasons for doing it
they say it's religious it's to give the
girl the opportunity for a husband in
the future whatever so this poor little
girl is really not consulted at any
moment but whether she wants it or not
is harmful and in some cases it's so
harmful and debilitating it leads to
paralysis it leads to death
children bleed to death it leads I can't
even begin to talk about the
psychological effects of once you
realize that a part of you has to go
because it's filthy and so you have to
realize that it's happening to children
yes it does happen outside of the United
States and now we are seeing those
cultures come here and carry on the
practice you know we have laws here that
purport to protect all children and what
you're doing by accepting this practice
or turning a blind eye to it is that
you're saying the United States laws
that protect all girls and women do not
protect these few golf from Egypt from
Sudan whose parents are from Egypt and
Sudan and Saudi Arabia and
India or Pakistan any of these countries
where it's commonplace to cut the
genitals of girls to mutilate and to
close them the law does not protect them
so you're quite literally saying we have
laws except for the people who need
those laws the most I mean it's the
height of absurdity it's the height of
absurdity again you go back to the
bigotry this is it's turning everything
if you are not a faces and you really
mean it then you should open up these
laws to little girls from these cultures
with forced marriages with honor
killings it's the same thing if you
believe that the law should protects all
women to own their own bodies and to
make their own choices then the same
laws should protect these girls the
girls who come to the AHA Foundation at
the age of 16 17 I'm being forced to
marry if I disagree I'm going to be
killed by my father we can't get law
enforcement to help out we give with we
you know we teach we train we've created
training manuals we talk to service
providers and all that but one thing
that I really think needs to become and
this is our aspiration the aspiration of
the AHA foundation is to make every
American aware of the fact that these
practices child marriage forced marriage
female genital mutilation on all
violence and honor killings are
happening right here and these
vulnerable women are excluded excluded
from the laws that protects us all yeah
so then I think as a perfect ending so
your foundation you've changed around a
few things you guys are growing I know
you're doing a partnership with basil
for people that want to get involved
because I do think we're getting some
wins here this type of stuff is starting
to resonate yeah how can they get well
beyond of course people can give money
and help get voices out and help find
some people that are in closed societies
and things like that yeah but what else
can people do volunteer work because if
what you know if you understand what the
problem is and you have the time you can
help us take that awareness volunteer
your time if you're good with social
media or other ways
reaching as many people as possible
please help us out if you are a teacher
if you are a policeman if you are any
other service provider somewhere in the
country and you're confronted with any
of these practices please let us know
yeah we are an activist group and again
we want to shine the light on these
terrible practices against women but we
also want to work with all other groups
that are targeted by Sharia we want to
work with the gay community we want to
work with the Jewish communities we want
to work with the Christian communities
nobody is really in the united very few
people there are few groups talk about
what is done to Christians in the Middle
East
these blasphemy laws etc and how this
whole thing is finding its way into
traditionally Christian countries yeah I
mean there's almost no Christians left
in the Middle East and yeah they've been
eradicated and even the ones that are
left and it's not just in Greece think
about the blasphemy laws in Pakistan
think about what happens to Christians
in Malaysia and Indonesia you know none
of this is really discussed in the way
it should be it should be headline news
every single day I believe until it
stops it should we should be pressuring
our government to tie economic political
diplomatic you know to use all of these
tools as a fashion method to stop these
persecutions the mainstream media is not
reporting once in a while you see every
part here or there but it's not a
campaign doesn't look like it's been
taken up and I think we should you know
make all of this as yeah I'm someone
who's really benefited from
globalization yeah I am an immigrant who
who is really grateful to have been
allowed here and in the Netherlands and
to have come out of this and I think my
duty as with other successful immigrants
is to make sure that we shine a light on
these atrocities yeah well I know it
truly is about being an individual
because you've inspired hundreds if not
I'm sure thousands of people including
me that got me to get have a little
bravery to do what I do and that that's
all we need so it's been a pleasure I
could talk to you all day but I know you
have a you have many more things to do
so I thank you for coming in and and for
you guys I do want to get involved check
out ions foundation it's aah a
foundation gorg
[Music]
you
[Music]